passengers on the moscow metro can now
pay for their commute using facial
recognition technology the system is
called face pay and connects passengers
biometric data to their credit cards
it's rolled out across all 241 stations
in the russian capital but private
activists are sounding the alarm
all he needs is his face to ride the
moscow metro vladimir biljakov has to
pause in front of the facial recognition
cameras set up at the ticket turnstiles
then he can get on his way
biljakov is one of around fifteen
thousand people who've been volunteering
to test the moscow metro's so-called
face pay system which has now been
opened to the wider public
usually you have to get out the right
card or you have to find your metropass
or your credit card in your backpack or
your pocket
here you don't have to find anything you
don't even have to take off your mask
you just walk up pass through and that's
it
test passengers had to provide a mobile
phone number credit card details and a
photo to register for face pay the
moscow metro assures users of the facial
recognition system that their personal
and biometric data won't be passed on to
third parties
the data is stored in a protected system
here
and people's bank details are stored on
the side of the banks themselves so they
are completely safe as well
moscow's department of transport says
face pay allows passengers to pay for
their ride three times faster than usual
the system is now in place on all 14
moscow metro lines and there are plans
to introduce it on other public
transportation like buses and streetcars
as well
above ground moscow already has over 200
thousand facial recognition cameras
after opposition protests earlier this
year police used footage from the
surveillance camera network to arrest
several demonstrators privacy
campaigners warned that the authorities
are expanding facial recognition
networks to gain more political control
the danger is they say the 220 000
facial recognition cameras are for our
safety but actually they're collecting
data
even the moscow mayor confirms from that
database it is clear who you spend time
with and for how long your social
circles will be identified that
information can definitely be used for
political purposes and against kremlin
critics
in moscow the reactions to the idea of
the facial recognition system on the
subway are mixed
we're losing control while it's becoming
easier for the government to control us
it's logical to have this system because
there is the danger of terrorist attacks
so i am in favor of it
i am conservative i guess i don't want
to sign up to face pay it's scary
face pay test passenger vladimir yakov
plans to keep using the system now that
it's being rolled out and he's not too
concerned about privacy issues
there's cameras everywhere already so i
don't think it's a big deal it doesn't
scare me
moscow's transport authority has
promised that for now traditional
payment methods for the city's metro
system will remain in use but they say
there may soon be a discount for anyone
who opts to pay using their biometric
data
i'm joined now by nasser dahmer a cyber
security expert from the fraunhofer
institute thank you for taking the time
to speak to dw now as we saw in that
report mixed reaction from people
technology prompts unique questions
mostly about privacy concerns now many
rights groups have voiced their concern
particularly with this facial
recognition and what that could mean in
terms of disadvantages for people what's
the most pressing concern that you have
so there are uh two main issues uh
regarding their privacy in this matter
is to use this system um in an unconsent
and out of regulation reasons and the
second part is that
the data the biometric data the facial
images are stored um in link with uh
identity the name for example
and
this link can be breached
even though it's it's it's secured and
this happened before for example in such
data that is used in the banking system
in the uk
okay so potentially that they could be
stored and it could be breached and uh
people that are not meant to see that
information could potentially see it now
russian civil rights groups have said
that the rights and responsibilities
associated with facial recognition is
not defined by law not in russia and not
in other places like europe are
countries doing enough to develop and
set a legal framework a clear one
um
yes and no um it varies a lot between
different countries for example in
europe there is quite a clear regulation
it's part of the general data protection
regulation
um specifically the
article 9 where the processing of
biometric data for the purpose of unique
identification of a person is prohibited
however this prohibition does not apply
in certain cases uh for example when the
person uh gives their consent uh to for
the data to be used for certain purpose
and for reasons of substantial public
interest for example or for this
establishment exercise
or defense of legal claims
other countries also have
a similar regulation for example the
japanese act for protection of personal
information and different
states the u.s have their own
regulations and they are mostly related
to the consent of the user to use this
data
now there's varying rules and
regulations perhaps not fully in place
in various kinds of countries but of
course this issue crosses borders do you
see a need need for a global legal
framework and do you think that's even
realistic
um
that will be quite difficult because you
will need to have a
jurisdiction
over all the countries and and
this is not the case there are general
global regulations that are related to
the united nations universal declaration
of human rights
that defines for example privacy as uh
fundamental rights but there is nothing
uh
that is cross-border uh that can be seen
as a cross-border regulation
cyber security expert nasser dahmer
thank you for your time and expertise
thanks very much
you